one of the most interesting things is
the confined spaces the the the heroes
in the can sort of approach and what
that opens up the opportunities and
challenges now you yourself you're a
veteran and you were a submariner
is that correct yeah I was a so nerman
on a fast attack submarine in a previous
life so I'm used to living inside a
weapon system which is the experience of
these gentlemen and it's it's a great
stage for a drama they can't get away
from each other and the scenery changes
so it just seems like a no-brainer to
stage a film and then but beyond that
because it's a period piece of course
that opens up a whole I started say can
but I won't say that it opens up a lot
of different opportunities and
challenges as well and you must have
done exhaustive research yeah I mean
it's interesting because you know World
War two movies were made starting in
World War two and there's quite a few
genre conventions and I didn't want to
repeat someone else's film I really
wanted to do something kind of new and
fresh so I did an incredible research
looking at period photographs that sit
at my desk for hours with a magnifying
glass just studying these photographs
and it was interesting doing you know a
period movie it's world creation
everything on the screen every asset you
see has to be generated painted built
constructed patina'd aged so it was kind
of a shock what we were in for the wet
Downs nature didn't cooperate you know
getting yelled at by production because
I needed like seven water Bowser's and
one of these locations to create all
that mud but it's that you know it's
that cohesiveness it's that that it just
blends visually and really becomes its
own sort of exhausted tired world which
is what it was at the end of the war
sure and for you guys I would imagine
this was quite the campaign I mean this
probably felt like obviously your lives
weren't at risk like the guys you were
portraying as often but maybe
occasionally but for you what
each see as the best challenge or the
biggest opportunities in this film well
for me I it was about I think about six
weeks of driving and just constantly you
know at first it was in a big field and
combs and I have to be honest it's like
when you have a Brad Pitt Shia LaBeouf
up the top and the turret you definitely
want to drive as best you can
I mean it's funny but it's it's not the
easiest thing to drive and it's a real
19 it's a real Sherman so you know when
these guys were goofing around and doing
whatever I'm just like making sure that
I'm driving
but I mean after five months I actually
I mean I think even before that like
after a month I got pretty good I saw in
the parking lot you're still yeah I like
drove an attack you know I was
fascinated by the idea of a tank crew
that had survived so long in the war and
the average lifespan of a tanker is
about six weeks it was really
catastrophic for us armored forces we we
hit the beaches at Normandy and
discovered we were just absolutely
outclassed by by the German armor and
lost a lot of guys so the idea of a tank
crew that had been together that long
and they did exist is something very
special and I didn't want to make a
movie about entirely about this jaded
embittered traumatised exhausted group
so I really needed you know the audience
surrogate which is Logan's character
someone who can come into this world
have things explained to him see the
world through fresh eyes and then also
whom we can study is an audience as as
this individual is transformed and
changed by war which is really what the
film is about it's not a battle movie
it's not about a famous event it's about
a family in a tank and it's about what
happens to a normal good dude when he's
put into this environment and it's it's
transformative and not in the best ways
and I mean to Logan's credit you know I
I fed these guys I fed their heads I fed
their hearts I gave them the research
the training etc but I never sat down
with Logan and
this is how you're gonna argue this
character this is how you're gonna get
from A to B that was really his job and
I really left that to him you know and I
kind of left that to the guys in general
gave him as much as possible but the
actual sort of tactical acting how they
deploy their characters over the film is
really their choice and and I mean Logan
nailed it you know every battle plan
changes as soon as the battle starts is
there anything in this film that you
really discovered in the process of
filming where it changed from the page
to the screen and a dramatic way it's
interesting we're pretty much shot on
book it was such a complex film that I
wasn't that confident really deviating
from the script so we pretty much shot
on book more than anything the action we
had inbound plans with the action
everything was storyboarded very complex
action sequences and then we get to set
and we're looking around and we're like
okay we got four days to do this this
storyboard here what would take a week
so let's rip him up and figure out what
we're gonna do
so that was scary that was really scary
and then somehow in editing go and shoot
all this action a lot of those shot as
masters and then try and discover the
intricacy and detail of the action and
editorial was was horrendous
it was a horrendous task I mean the
editors killed it on this because it did
not come off the set in a readily
understandable way and for you what was
it in the script what was it in this
project that you most connected with
that made you make this film your next
choice well I mean it was a it's an
incredible read it was it was one of the
the only times probably the second time
that I read a script and and knew I had
to do it it was the only thing I wanted
to do and I you know I expressed that to
David I told him I wouldn't work that
year if I didn't do it really wasn't
anything else I was excited about for me
it's different from the
that's out there for people my age a lot
of the material out different people my
age you're not very challenging to put
it that way just say I mean the whole
experience for me was just about
immersing myself I mean for all of us
really just immersing ourselves and our
characters you know world and what we
were living in and dedicating our year
you know as we worked in this film for a
good nine months I'd say to research an
authenticity and not corrupting the
experience with fun and being a tourist
and doing things in-between you know in
between takes - to take us out of our
zone we stayed in our element we we we
dedicated ourselves to David's process
which is very unique and to say the
least and what tell us a little bit
about it well I'd say the key to David's
process is to not know what's coming
next
yeah ready for whatever yeah yeah yeah
usually there's a lot of whatever tossed
in there yeah it's a lot of curveballs I
mean we get in the vans and not know
where we're going or what was gonna be
coming next
that's like you were kidnapped actually
create yeah it was like that sometimes
the vans we blacked out - we really
would not have any idea where we were
going
I don't tell him he was playing Patty
Hearst I was sort of fascinated by the
tracer fire and and the visual things
that came with that I didn't know for
instance that they were color coded by
who was shooting that was something that
we haven't seen a lot of films yeah
machine gun rounds are loaded every you
know fourth fifth round is it contains a
phosphorus base and the phosphorus is
chemically colored so American tracer
rounds pink red Germans or Green
Japanese or purple or blue
you know you've seen like the old
gunsight footage from say Corsairs in
the Pacific you know I grew up as a kid
seeing that sort of stuff and I was
always really compelled by it so we went
to this crazy extreme you know muzzle
velocities and distances and all this
sort of calculations we did with the
special effects houses it was shockingly
difficult to get these tracers correct
we had so many vendors and we're just
beating them with iterations up until we
released the film it was really
difficult to get correct a lot of times
when filmmakers look back to World War
two in particular we see the movies they
have like a certain kind of a gauzy look
or a kind of a newsreel or
black-and-white or a patina to it of
some kind it seemed like you would in a
very different direction with that as
well yeah I mean there's sort of
conventions in the genre the the narrow
shutter angle for the action the the
uncoated lenses the you know bleached
out kind of look we went for open blacks
saturated if we shot film was shot
g-series lenses and we treated the film
like film so even though we did a scan
and a DI we applied old school film
lights and instead of just pushing
digital data around we really treated it
like film as if we were you know giving
orders to a lab on how to print and with
with the organic quality the way film
loves faces the way film blends and then
you know the way film can see
differentiations and colors there's so
much green and brown in this you know
had we shot digital a lot of that data
would have been lost it would have could
come off the set I mean film really is
just unbelievable all shoot film until
they stopped making it yeah fantastic
exactly